all right well mike let's let's talk
about some real things that are going on
okay
let's talk about some things that i
can't believe that this is the third
time when i don't want to do this i'm
going to do it anyway
so orman benjamin was drinking
interpreting last we left him
here we go and uh saying that uh jordan
peterson's wife never really had cancer
well mike
did you think he could get crazier royce
it's owen benjamin it can always get
crazier
give it to me in utah hi so
you know i've been ladling the gravy
pretty hard lately
what and what is better than a nice
relaxing
end of the day kick off your shoes
you know have a nice beverage
unwind and have a book burning
right because my
uh the wife and the kids are having
dinner at her mom's tonight which i
usually
why aren't you there wow that is very
telling
wow we really enjoy going to but i've
been on a pretty intense um
detox diet that's why he's not there
turpentine
that's why he's not so he's not he's not
with his wife
and her mother and his kids because he's
on a detox i.e
drinking paint thinner somebody uh get
this
i'm gonna read this games you love this
always happens we don't talk about owen
for like eight nine months like we
didn't why don't you talk about own we
talk about owen
always picking on owen there's so many
people online to insult why big
bear okay oh there it is there it is you
let it slip
because he's drinking pink dinner and
not spending time with his kids and his
in-laws that's why and it gets a little
worse no sugar or bread and her mother
in her
let no no pause this if you are
defending owen benjamin
right now after all of this recent
activity you are a pathetic piece of
[ __ ]
if you're still calling a grown man that
is not your father or related to you big
bear
while he drinks turpentine and misses
his kid's law
misses out on his kids lives you don't
just
listen to me you don't deserve
to have a seat at the table you do not
deserve to have an opinion
the intense um detox diet
of no sugar or bread and her mother and
her
uh to give her credit is an unbelievable
cook
so i don't think there was any way i was
going to uh withstand some of her
cooking
so i tapped out and so what's the best
thing to do when you're home alone
without the family
hold on let's give reasonable answers
and then we'll do this mike what's the
best thing to do when you're home alone
without the family
productive or unproductive well let's do
productive first productive
hey you know you do a little vacuuming
maybe clean up a little bit maybe
organize the garage
you should yeah they got a lot of um
farm animals milk the goats yeah you
know you do some stuff like that
maybe um but like also in the
unproductive category
just enjoy a little peace and quiet pop
the tv on right
maybe play some video games for me smoke
a cigar
for me productive organize some of our
patreon stuff sure
you know because you have just real time
they'd sit there and kind of edit some
clips that i've been wanting to edit for
a while
stuff like that maybe work on some
things for the show um
unproductive jerk off it's always a good
one and you're homeless it's a chance
and um you know what pink hear that
little ps4 turn on
yeah it's like grand theft auto baby
yeah man play some you know a little
rust or something
yeah yeah yeah because you can't do that
when you're married you've got kids
there's a lot you always got to be
vigilant and then it's like no you know
what i'm gonna hang back the house and
then they go and you're like yeah like
where is it
let's see what let's see what does big
bear do
do when you're home alone without the
family rifle through
your son's books that
may not have sat right with you and you
don't want to do it in front of them
but when you have something called
fossils tell a tale of long ago
forest diversity dinosaur wide evolution
lie
it's time for a good old-fashioned
fireside chat plus
some book burning
you're good you're good he
his his
he waited till they left
he's gonna burn [ __ ] while they're like
i want to break this down for you
because you could talk about he's crazy
in the dinosaur stuff and the whatever
and you know whatever
cool fine but
it's also very telling that he waited
until they left the house
to do it right like that's that's almost
like a violation of
of his of his of his relationship right
like isn't that
like that's that shows deception on his
part that shows that no there's no way i
could have brought this up to amy she
would have [ __ ] lost her mind on me
yeah so i'm gonna wait until she goes
and then i'm gonna burn the kids
and then i'll deal with the consequences
right that's that is
forget forget the the crazy and the
turpentine and the dino stuff
and the flat forget all that that's so
hard let's just i know but
let's just keep this simple right now
let's look at this from a pathological
point of view
that's sick that's that's that's a
that's a weird
like that's a weird i'm gonna hide this
from that's
[ __ ] weird dude that's he is a he's
gone
he's [ __ ] this is the worst he's ever
been he dude he's drinking turpentine
and burning his child's books
like that's not even a punch line
okay one minute in
good to see you guys good to see you
okay good to see you too because i can't
stand reading these books too all right
let's first start with
dinosaur rocket as you can see
and don't get me wrong sorry i'm
interrupting a lot but don't get me
wrong
this would actually make a hilarious bit
you know what i mean like if you were
not already crazy and you're just
[ __ ] people like
this would make a great like if you just
went out to like a store and bought some
dinosaur folks just to do this like if
you weren't owen
if you just wanted to like joke around
about how dinosaurs aren't real and
you're like oh yeah my kids aren't home
right now so i'm burning the dinosaur
books
like having a beer people go that's
funny that's a funny [ __ ] but this is
real
he really doesn't think dinosaurs
existed this is a real thing that he
believes a new a new a new thing by the
way a new thing that he's clung to yeah
um this right here is the lunar rover
oops oops
dinosaur rocket he's taking too much
trouble
and taking something away from his kid
too right instead of taking joy by
eating dinner with his family and his
in-laws
which let's be fair fine nobody enjoys
that but you still go
yeah of course stereotaps allosaurus all
these
these dinosaurs by penny dale
yeah somebody says it seems like a sam
hyde [ __ ]
yeah that would be something that sam
dinosaur rocket waiting waiting on the
launch pad on the launch pad having
final checks
wow this is going to be a really good
book
check here's the thing with this
dinosaur book
by by the way this dinosaur book isn't
even
like a history because he let's say he
doesn't believe dinosaurs don't exist
which is nuts but fine
never existed fine this book isn't even
whether dinosaurs exist or not it's
supposed to be like you know
the the tv show dinosaurs like these
dinosaurs are in a car driving to see
like it's a cartoon it's like [ __ ]
care bears or something like
why like
i don't believe in dragons
but if i had a kid and he wanted to read
a book about dragons i'd
let him read it like what is
what does it matter owen somebody said
here uh he just implied that these are
the books that his son
asks him to read he might be burning his
kids favorite books
oh you're right that makes it way worse
oh my god
and he's just whoops like like
wouldn't you feel aw like honestly any
parent in the world right
if if you're if your kid is doing
something that isn't good for them
even even then a parent should feel some
mild degree of bad right like you should
still feel bad when you
when you take something from a kid and
they get really sad
even if it's the best thing for them you
it should be one of those things where
you go man
it should be a lesson this hurts that i
gotta you know this kid's gonna cry and
i feel terrible but i gotta do this
because it's best for the kid he's
taking
joy in this which is another [ __ ]
sick pathological thing
check astronaut dinosaurs riding riding
on the bus on the bus to the
these are all the things that he hates
think about this this book is owen's
nightmare
it's astronaut dinosaurs that are going
to the moon
and maybe they're jewish obviously the
dinosaurs are jewish
so it's jewish astronaut dinosaurs going
to them this is oh no
no no no they're astronauts so they're
nazis you're right yeah
by the way game i got to say this the
person that was saying this earlier
just wrote he paid for them it's his
property he's burning all right this
person's definitely [ __ ] yeah he's
gotta be
happy it's definitely being funny
i fell for it at first but when i read
that i'm like okay you got it he's
messing you're [ __ ] dizzy
you're a [ __ ] dick well played though
it's his property the giant rocket
room vroom vroom that's a lie
lie lie lie lie lie
so my boy will never bring this book to
me again and say dead dad will you read
me this book
that hurts my feelings like honestly
i'll say like that that that
fact that somebody brought it up and
it's a really good point the kid
probably really enjoys reading these
books
and he's enjoying this now we're having
a good old-fashioned book
burning room as you can see the media
here
brave dinosaurs climbing climbing into
the rocket into the rocket right on the
top
you see the media there you see
there's the hey you weren't wrong again
and then he's like yeah dad are you
going to read this book not anymore like
again the [ __ ] joy he's taking in
this you know
it's like if if you love your kids
and your kids like um oh i wanna
i want another soda i wanna drink
another soda tonight dad and you go
i can't give you another soda it's just
you know what i mean you can't have too
much soda it's not good for you don't go
to sleep
and and then they start crying and they
feel better you take something
a soda away from them right you should
still have this this little thing in
your way like i feel so bad i'm just
robbing joy of this kid
but i'm doing it because it's best for
him this is like
ha ha hey dada read the dinosaur book
[ __ ] you bear burn it's like what the
[ __ ] is
that's that's a that's a sick that's a
sick thing to to take joy in right
look burning clank clank clank
nervous dinosaurs pressing buttons
pressing buttons and waiting to start
waiting to start
frankie the whop says no you burn
something they love to teach them a
lesson of course
you're right that's way better great
good fellows reference by the way
oh what are they gonna do are they gonna
are they gonna get on the rocket and go
to the moon
oh book burning the countdown to launch
ten nine eight seven
six the countdown to your force four
three
two one and it's off being burned
somebody said fire is hot
mr 147 iq ladies and gentlemen
dinosaur rocket roaring roaring and
thundering into space into space zooming
faster and faster zoom
misrepresentation of the earth
and what looks like oh also round earth
oh we forgot to add something to all the
things in this book that he hates
do you know if a children book about
astronaut dinosaurs bothers you this
much you're probably mentally like i i'm
not even insane like you're you're
you're you're [ __ ] dumb and the
amount of people that eat this up
because this bothers me right obviously
this bothers me because
what he's doing to his kid but there is
not all of them but there's some people
that watch him just to laugh at him but
he's gonna he's gonna influence other
people to to give their children
bad lives to feed them turpentine and to
burn their toys
this is like this isn't you know it's
funny because when royce and i
talked about this video before the show
we were like of course we got to cover
it you know we were like cracking jokes
and stuff but now that we're watching it
it's like it's not even funny
yeah this is like you know what i mean
this is [ __ ] this is really making me
[ __ ] sick
you know i had some really [ __ ] up uh
i
really [ __ ] up upbringing and my
parents were not perfect
but i can't even imagine my [ __ ] up
dad
ever doing something like this and
taking joy in
in it you know like it's it's dude
wow man this this poor [ __ ] kid man
yeah
like a penis not by accident
excited dinosaurs whizzing whizzing on
the moon broom
out of the moon in the dinosaur buggies
[Music]
proud dinosaurs posing posing with their
flag the flag of the first dinosaurs on
the moon
the media is right there wow let's see
what's on the next page
and if anybody wants to say this is uh
ir uh ironic or something
no owen that's not what i'm gonna use to
describe this ironic would not be the
word
pathetic infuriating insane sad
heartbreaking mm-hmm
dying marriage i i don't i i can't
again this is a big part of it because
if you are going to take but
you're going back to each other taking
somebody from the kid if you are going
to take something away from your kid
you also supposed to explain to them why
right like the soda thing was like
look you can't have soda because it's
late and you're not going to sleep and
you've already had enough sugar okay
to take some like it's like when your
kid goes to school
and you were just to throw away his toys
when he came you'd be like
why'd you throw away why'd you throw
away my toys
this is just he's three they don't
understand this
this is just if he's three
and they don't understand it he
understands enough to walk up to you and
say dada can you read this book
lies being put in their head somebody
just said too
just burn it already sicko yeah it's the
way he's savoring this
yeah burn the whole book he's savoring
this the way i save her a porterhouse
steak yeah
you know what i mean just each bite is a
slow hmm
as we're on the moon flash flash flash
laughing dinosaurs playing playing
floating in space
kick they're playing soccer and space
[Applause]
just kick off your shoes ladies and
gentlemen there's a nice therapeutic
i want to punch this [ __ ] guy in his
face right now am i the only one
no he's just like this is one of those
things where you just have no problem
just
popping them be like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
good old-fashioned all-american
therapeutic enthusiastic
book burning floating in space and
playing soccer kick
quiet dinosaur stopping stopping to look
at their planet
the blue planet so far away home home
all wise yes
owen yeah no you're right you're right
in that um
that there are no space-faring
astronaut dinosaurs you're right that
there's no dinosaurs
driving cars in space i get that but
did you know gi joes isn't a real branch
of the military we all read
a lot of things as a kid that was just
silly right like oh look at this this is
a story of a
of a goat who who who lives on a volcano
on mars
that sounds good if it makes sense but
like when you're a kid it's all about
when you're when you're a kid it's all
about learning to easy three it's all
about learning to read
forming sentences comprehension
colors shapes you know what i mean the
whole point of a book is to just keep
your brain like right
oh look at the oh wow okay the kid
doesn't grow up and think
you're dead were there dinosaurs on the
moon can i break this down a little bit
more
sure so so he thinks that
the secret illuminati
grabbler media is trying to
indoctrinate children with
dinosaur spaceships and round earth
sounds about right all right think about
it that way then they'll keep earning it
owen obviously
i'm not this is what we taught man i
talk about we talk about conspiracy
people all the time
and we're the first ones to go there's
some [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up there's some
[ __ ] i don't buy
absolutely i'm i'm a big proponent of
questioning things right
but holy [ __ ] do some people
throw the baby out with the bath water
some people go
just cause some things are [ __ ] doesn't
mean other things aren't like you know
what i mean like
owen thinks because he has a problem
with
that there were no dinosaurs like he
he also misses any logical steps to get
those to those decisions
he and you know what owen
maybe public school isn't the best place
to for your children to be taught
i could maybe i could get on board with
that maybe it's not
but you're a worse alternative like you
are a worse
some people are a better alternative
homeschooling their kids you're the
worst alternative here
because this kid's gonna be so [ __ ] up
and you know what happens and mike i'm
sure you worked at a strip club so you
know
a lot of people that have parents that
are this rough on them
and that are this insane and don't let
them read books and you're not allowed
to watch tv
the moment they have any freedom
they go the opposite direction and they
do [ __ ]
terrible things right uh they they
become hookers
they [ __ ] to [ __ ] you my dad never might
my dad villainized sex for me so i'm
gonna suck every dick on the street
that's that's what happens with this
you're creating monsters
you're not you're not helping your kid
you think you know better owen you you
think you could run your kid's life you
can't even run your own life
you've literally burned every bridge
you've ever had
and you think that you were right doing
it you think you're the winner
you think that everybody here's the
thing owen you think buddy everybody's
laughing with you everybody's laughing
at you
you're a joke because you know you said
the first hour that the comedians are
laughing behind crowder's back
do you know what they're probably
thinking about owen
you have become one of the
weirdest most unhinged people now look
i don't know if you're doing all this
book burning because you're legit i do
you think you're crazy because you're
legitimately crazy
or because maybe you're not on youtube
anymore and you're trying to get that
juice back
you know i don't know trying to get the
what back
juice oh okay happy
dinosaurs blasting off a space on their
way home
by they say hooray they land in the
ocean oh oh oh oh no it's burning hero
dinosaur splashing down splashing down
safe and sound safe and sound back on
earth
hooray outside broadcast vehicle
rigid inflatable boat moon buggy rockets
every single thing on this page is
either evil or a lie
everything so i remember a while back
he was talking about the dinosaur thing
when he started getting into the
dinosaurs
fake thing and he even said something
effective like yeah my kid has books on
dinosaurs
like and he didn't say like he was gonna
do anything about it he was just saying
like yeah whatever you know my kids got
booked on dinosaurs whatever and now
it's turned into this this is
here's another dinosaur book hot melted
stone from a volcano
filled the dinosaur's footprint in the
mud the stone cooled and hardened
a few years ago fossil hunters called
now i'm scared
the royal society i'm not going to pin
it on anybody your kid's going gonna
come home and have one of the only
things he loves gone
[Laughter]
it's hilarious owen like this is i i
understand this i would be
uh nervous to live in a house with him
of course
dug through the stone they found an
exact imprint of a dinosaur's foot
oh no way their funding depended on it
what are the odds
not all the fossils were found in stone
some were found in the frozen ground of
the arctic
this ancient mammoth was a kind of
elephant
it was frozen is he now implying okay
fine you don't believe in dinosaurs
is he implying that mammoths weren't
real because we've actually found them
frozen like in perfect condition
yeah but if you personally found them
rice i guess i didn't personally find
them mike then
checkmates and thousands of years ago it
was found
not long ago buried in the frozen ground
the grass it had been eaten
was still in its mouth
what could have killed it and what could
have found it
i'm gonna say this right now and i'm
gonna go on a record if if amy stays
with him after this
i have absolutely no sympathy for her
after this i do feel bad for the kids
i feel terrible for the kids but if amy
stays with him after this
she is a big as big a piece of [ __ ] as
he is in my opinion
funding the mammoth was fresh enough to
eat
whoa really some
someone who ate a piece said it was that
is true that's actually a story that's
that's true that they did find
a frozen mammoth and they they cook
little pieces of it re this
about 50 60 years ago cooked little
pieces of it and
and ate it dry and not very tasty
but what could you expect from an
ancient mammoth
although the children we just saw were
all oddly diverse
every scientist here looks like they're
from the same
tribe black curly hair bald
and male it's almost no female
no i don't know how do they reproduce
it's weird like amoebas
yeah they osmosis okay also like
it's almost like the science class the
the this class of this priest class of
scientists
they don't follow the same did he say
priest class
i think i guess it's hard to keep up
with this [ __ ] anymore man
i'm really angry at this prick right now
type of
forced integration that the children
do that i just burned
oh it's almost like programming of who
your master is going to be can't wait to
burn this one
the joy he's taking in this is what
really bothers me
yeah like if he just if he just sternly
went i got to get rid of these books
because dinosaurs aren't real and i
can't have my son getting his brain all
[ __ ] up
that in itself would be [ __ ] up enough
but it's just he takes it to that level
where it's like
to to enjoy it to to to extract any
level of joy from it
is [ __ ] psychotic of a pine tree
the sap hardened and became a fossil
called
amber amber alert
amber looks like yellow people find him
funny because that's the other thing man
people you know these [ __ ] crazy
people that follow him
always come like oh yeah owens [ __ ] is
he funny when's owen been funny
leftist sports when was owen funny
oh glass the fly was perfectly preserved
inside of amber
i can't wait to read this again oh oh oh
oh
[ __ ] you're a hack on top of
everything on top of being a [ __ ]
lunatic and a cree
because that's the thing because look at
worst at worst at worst at worst
um owen is a [ __ ] lunatic
crazy person who believes his stuff at
best he's a terrible grifter that's
influencing other people to believe
crazy [ __ ] either one of those things
are not great right
oops this is bad other insects and even
plants have been preserved in amber
there's a spider a cockroach but we but
we have found insects preserved in
in amber have you not seen the
documentary jurassic park
we must we have learned many things from
the fish
the fern the fly and yeah balison's got
a good point because you think he's
doing this to spite his wife i don't
know but
you gotta wonder and of course we don't
know what happened but you gotta wonder
if there was a conversation where owen
was like uh
owen was like are you uh are you
or amy amy i don't want the kids to read
these books
i don't want them and amy was like owen
let the cat get the kids have their do
your show but let the kids have their
books
let the kids have their books it's fine
don't be crazy owen leave them alone
yeah fine i'm not going to dinner
tonight though
and i'm definitely not going to burn
their books somebody just pointed out to
go look he has
5.1 000 people watching him
right now live right now
and yeah it's this
is i i don't know who who would
unironically watch him at this point
this is
like i i i like again man it's not even
funny